welcome to another famous friday i
believe that whatever goal you have
whatever challenge you're facing right
now it has already been solved by
somebody else and the fastest way to
solve it yourself is to model that
success learn what worked for them and
apply it to your business as well so
today i want to look at the success
behind hewlett packard and their lesson
is adapt
the plan you start with is very rarely
going to be the plan that actually makes
you successful and you're going to need
to adapt and change and it's okay if
your first plan doesn't work out because
it rarely does so william hewlett and
dave packard started hewlett-packard
with
538 dollars they were young engineers
they didn't have a lot of startup
capital they started in in dave
packard's backyard one car garage and
they flipped a coin over whose name
would be first
william hewlett won so it became
hewlett-packard instead of
packard hewlett their very first product
was a foul line indicator for bowling
alley so if you're bowling and your foot
goes cross the line it's going to send
you a notification and it was ingenious
it was different it was new never been
done before but there was a problem
nobody wanted the product they couldn't
convince bowling alleys to buy it and so
this is a really important point because
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
that's where they give up that's where
they quit right say well we put
everything we had into it this was our
big idea it didn't work out i took my
shot you know i tried
so
maybe i'm not meant to be an
entrepreneur i'm gonna go back and get a
job but hewlett-packard
didn't take that mentality instead they
adapted and they said you know what our
first product didn't work out we're
gonna adapt and we're gonna try
something new so their next product they
came out with was the hp 200a and what
it was was a tool to help
measure
instruments and tune harmonicas
and they released it to the market and
again they had very little success with
it but one young entrepreneur named walt
disney decided to buy eight of them for
a movie he was making called fantasia
and their tool was used to help make the
movie
and they were excited that somebody had
used it somebody had bought so many of
them and they thought you know maybe
this product can work but we need to
adapt how we're selling it and so they
said let's try doing direct mail
marketing and they wrote out a few
letters to people saying you know
promoting their product and how great it
was and some orders started to trickle
in so they started to do more and more
and more orders came in and that was the
growth of hewlett-packard and so the
first product didn't work out but they
adapted the first marketing strategy
they used didn't work and so they
adapted and hewlett pack continued to
adapt over the years and they're a
company known for innovation and
adaptation and they launched tons of new
products they not only created new
product lines but also adapted the way
business was done they were one of the
first companies to introduce flex hours
and
profit sharing for employees they
created a culture called the hp way at a
time when there wasn't corporate culture
their their one car backyard garage is
now considered the birthplace of silicon
valley and is a museum that you can go
and see and so
all along the way
they continue to adapt to improve their
business and that's what you need to do
because it's very rare that your first
idea is going to work that your first
marketing strategy is going to work that
your first employee that you hire is
going to work it almost doesn't work out
and that's okay and that's normal and
that happens to everybody the key to the
winners the ones that make it the
entrepreneurs who make it through and
achieve their goals are the ones who
continue to adapt to change to make it
better to take the feedback that they're
getting and find another way to stand so
adapt
and believe
for those of you watching like the video
you can subscribe to the channel to see
more videos just like this thank you so
much for watching i'll see you soon